¿Cuál ha sido el país más próspero, el
país que más ha crecido en Sudamérica durante
los últimos 40 años?
Tenéis 3 segundos para responder:
3, 2, 1…..
¡Exacto!
Seguido muy de cerca por Panamá y Uruguay,
Chile se alza con la primera plaza.
Ha sido el país de Sudamérica que mejor
desempeño económico y social ha tenido durante
las últimas 4 décadas.
Durante este tiempo Chile ha pasado de ser
uno de los países más pobres de todo el
continente a posicionarse junto a Uruguay
como el país más desarrollado y próspero
de América Latina.
(Desde finales del siglo XX Chile ha experimentado
un desarrollo más que notable y todos los
indicadores económicos y sociales han mejorado:
Desde los años 90 y gracias a un proceso
de crecimiento regular muy habitual en la
región los niveles de producción económica
de Chile se han multiplicado casi por 4 al
tiempo que el número de personas en situación
de pobreza se ha desplomado más de un 75%.
Hoy Chile ocupa a nivel de América Latina
el primer lugar en el Índice de Desarrollo
Humano de Naciones Unidas, el primer puesto
en el Índice de Libertad Humana, la segunda
plaza en el Índice de Prosperidad Global,
también el segundo puesto en el Índice de
Percepción de la Corrupción y la tercera
posición en el Índice de calidad democrática)
Es decir, aunque con muchos peros, de los
que ya os hemos hablado en pasados vídeos,
con los datos en la mano podemos decir que
Chile lo ha hecho razonablemente bien durante
las últimas décadas.
Al menos en el contexto de América Latina.
Sin embargo, pese a ello los últimos años
no han sido particularmente buenos, ni en
términos económicos ni tampoco sociales.
Por ejemplo, entre el año 2014 y el año
2021, el PIB per cápita real, apenas creció
a una tasa anualizada del 0,9%.
Un registro muy pobre para un país que todavía
tiene que converger con los más ricos.
De hecho, para que os hagáis una idea, el
PIB per cápita real de Estados Unidos creció
durante el mismo periodo de tiempo a una tasa
anual de casi el 1,4%, esto es, un 55% más
que el crecimiento registrado en Chile.
Así que la distancia entre estos dos países
no solo no se ha recortado sino que se ha
incrementado de forma relevante.
Concretamente en más de 4.600 dólares per
cápita.
Y desde el punto de vista social las cosas
no han marchado mucho mejor: durante los últimos
años el conflicto mapuche - os hablamos de
ello hace poco aquí en VisualPolitik - ha
incrementando su intensidad y, luego, las
protestas del 2019 pusieron al país patas
arriba y alimentaron una ola violencia de
una intensidad no vista en mucho tiempo.
Algo que por cierto terminó con un proceso
constituyente y con Grabiel Boric como presidente
de Chile.
Pues bien, el 4 de septiembre de 2022 los
chilenos decidirán en referéndum si aprobar
o rechazar esta nueva Constitución.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Según las encuestas la mayoría de los chilenos
están….
En contra de la propuesta.
La mayoría sigue siendo.
sí, partidaria de cambiar la Constitución
en vigor, que está heredada de la época
de Pinochet.
Pero están en contra del texto aprobado por
la Asamblea Constituyente.
De hecho incluso si se llega a aprobar, lo
hará teniendo a la mitad del país claramente
en contra y a la mayoría de los chilenos
profudnamente decepcionados.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
[Por cierto, en Latinoamérica cada vez que
se habla de una crisis inevitablemente surge
el debate: el de dolarizar la economía.
Queridos amigos, el dólar lleva casi 80 años
ocupando una posición hegemónica en el sistema
monetario internacional.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué supone exactamente para
los Estados Unidos que el dólar sea la divisa
de referencia mundial?
¿A qué futuro se enffrenta la moneda del
Tío Sam?
Pues bien, si quieres conocer las respuestas
a estas preguntas no te puerdes perder uno
de los últimos vídeos de Si lo Hubiera Sabido,
el canal de información financiera de Mutactivos
con el que participamos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción]
Dicho esto, continuemos.
T1(LOS GRANDES INTERROGANTES DE LA NUEVA CONSTITUCIÓN)
El proceso constituyente de Chile está llegando
a su fin, la Convención terminó su trabajo
y el borrador de nueva Constitución ya está
sobre la mesa.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué supone exactamente la nueva
Carta Magna?
¿Por qué está generando tantas dudas entre
los propios chilenos?¿Cómo puede afectar
al futuro económico y político del país?
Pues bien, son muchas las críticas que se
le han hecho a esta propuesta desde, ojo,
todos los puntos del espectro político de
Chile.
Unas críticas que, tal y como hemos visto,
han hecho que a la mayoría de los chilenos
simple y llanamente no les guste.
Y como evidentemente no podemos repasarla
de principio a fin, en este vídeo lo que
nos interesa es echar un vistazo a las principales
críticas.
Pues bien, en primer lugar, la nueva Constitución
define a Chile como una república solidaria,
de democracia inclusiva y paritaria y también
como un Estado plurinacional, en el que por
ejemplo se reconocen 11 naciones indígenas.
Es decir, como veis, da la sensación de que
la Constitución quiere abarcarlo todo.
El problema que tienen estas constituciones
tan amplias es que suelen llevar el poder
político a todos los rincones, al tiempo
que introducen muchas rigideces.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de las naciones indígenas
la nueva Constitución no sólo les reconoce
una cierta autonomía, lo cuál puede estar
bien, sino que también acepta sus propios
sistemas de justicia.
La pregunta es, ¿cómo se puede articular
un estado de derecho moderno con modelos judiciales
basados en la tradición y las viejas constumbres?
¿Quiere decir esto que no todos los chilenos
se enfrentarán al mismo modelo de justicia?
Pues no, lo cierto es que parece que no.
C2(“No hemos renunciado a ningún derecho,
pero esta nueva propuesta va más allá, colisionando
y pasando por encima de los derechos de los
ciudadanos no indígenas” Hugo Alcamán,
presidente de la corporación de profesionales
mapuche ENAMA)
Y ojo que esto podría tener consecuencias
muy serias.
Por ejemplo, Chile se ha convertido en el
tercer mayor exportador de drogas ilegales
a Europa.
Y un sistema judicial tan fragmentado podría
ser utilizado por algunos grupos criminales
para obtener ventaja.
Y, ojo, esto es algo que en cierta forma denucian,
incluso, algunos líderes indígenas.
Fijaos.
C3(“Siempre hemos peleado porque en ciertos
niveles podamos resolver nuestros problemas.
Pero en el nivel de la policía local.
Temas de vecinos.
Pero pasar a llevar la justicia donde vamos
a tener privilegios con respecto a un chileno
no indígena, indudablemente la población
se va a rebelar contra eso”.
Hugo Alcamán, presidente de la corporación
de profesionales mapuche ENAMA)
De hecho, la propuesta también reconoce las
Autonomias territoriales indígenas.
Estos territorios tendrían así libertad
para establecer regímenes económicos y administrativos
diferentes que, además, no estarían sujetos
a la vigilancia y fiscalización del Estado.
¿Otro ejemplo?
La nueva Constitución exige que todos, absolutamente
todos los órganos del estado estén formados
al menos por un 50% de mujeres.
Y a ver, no me malinterpreteis, está bien
favorecer la igualdad y la participación
de la mujer en todos los órganos polítocos
y públicos, faltaría más, pero la crítica
es comprensible: ¿tiene sentido que la Consitutución,
ni siquiera una ley, sino la propia Constitución
fije un mínimo del 50%?
¿Cómo se puede gestionar algo así en la
práctica?
¿Y si no es posible hacerlo en un determinado
órgano?
¿Cómo encaja aquí la cuestión del mérito
y la propia igualdad?
¿Qué ocurre, por ejemplo, con el ejército?
¿No sería acaso mejor regular este tipo
de cosas mediante leyes?
Pensad que las constituciones no nacen con
un espiritu temporal.
No sé, son preguntas cuyas respuestas no
están muy claras.
Pero esta cuestión es quizás la menos importante.
La nueva Constitución también elimina importantes
contrapesos políticos.
Por ejemplo se carga el Senado para sustituirlo
por una “Cámara de las Regiones”, cuyo
papel genera muchas dudas.
De hecho, esto es algo que ha sido criticado
duramente por el Presidente del Senado, el
destacado miembro del Partido Socialista de
Chile, Álvaro Antonio Elizalde
N1(Senado cuestiona creación de Cámara de
las Regiones: “No cumple un estándar mínimo"
"Lo que se aprobó no cumple un estándar
mínimo de una regulación coherente para
tener un adecuado sistema político que corresponda
a nuestra democracia”expresó Alvaro Elizalde.
El Dinamo)
Por otra parte, el texto contempla la creación
del llamado Consejo de la Justicia, un órgano
cuya función será nombrar y cesar a los
jueces y funcionarios del sistema de Justicia.
¿El problema?
Su composición será mayoritariamente política.
Es decir, los políticos nombrarán, cesarán,
premiarán y castigarán a los jueces que
tienen que tienen la misión de controlar
a los propios políticos….
No sé, como poco genera dudas.
Pero…
Seguimos
(La Constitución también plantea grandes
cambios en el modelo económico que han suscitado
grandes críticas.
Por ejemplo, el mecanismo de expropiación
es mucho más ambiguo respecto a las compensaciones
públicas que la Constitución en vigor; no
se reconoce la propiedad intelectual e industrial
a excepción de los derechos de autor, y se
pone fin al régimen de propiedad que hasta
ahora tenían los derechos de uso de las aguas
y las concesiones de explotación minera.
Con el nuevo texto, ambos derechos perderán
su estatus de propiedad para pasar a depender
de las decisiones administritativas de funcionariaros
estatales.
Esto supone entre otras cosas que no se podrán
vender, alquilar o utilizar para otras actividades.
Lo que evidentemente creará mucha incertidumbre
e inseguridad jurírica en sectores como la
agricultura, la minería o la industria que
requieran un suministro regular y abundante
de agua.)
Y claro, la pregunta es,, ¿Construiriais
algo sobre arenas movedizasa o arenas que
mueva el funcionario de turno?
Seguro que no.
Pues bien, en una línea muy similar, el texto
le confiere al presidente la capacidad de
convocar una “Comisión Territorial Indígena”
para expropiar terrenos a lo largo y ancho
de todo el país y devolverselos a las comunidades
indígenas.
Un proceso que, para colmo, no sería nada
rápido sino que se prolongaría indefinidamente
en el tiempo y que podría afectar a familias
que llevan siendo propietarias de las tierras
desde hace generaciones.
C5(“Muchos dueños de los campos no van
a querer vender, porque llevan 4 generaciones
acá.
Dicen: No seré mapuche pero soy hombre de
la tierra.
[...] Porque el abuelo, el nieto, nacieron
ahí.
La confrontación que se nos viene es enorme
por el tema de la compra de tierras.
Hugo Alcamán, presidente de la corporación
de profesionales mapuche ENAMA)
Y por supuesto la pregunta es, ¿quién en
su sano juicio estaría dispuesto a invertir
un sólo dólar en las regiones más susceptibles
de que se produzcan estas expropiaciones?
Y aún no hemos terminado.
La nueva Constitución parece querer sindicalizar
la economía chilena casi a niveles argentinos.
Por ejemplo, se deja muy claro que no se podrá
prohibir ni limitar, las huelgas y las acciones
sindicales salvo en casos muy extraordinarios.
Además, también se impone la negociación
colectiva sectorial y estas organizaciones,
los sindicatos, tendrán, incluso, derecho
a participar en la toma de decisiones de las
propias empresas.
Ojo con esta cuestión.
Pero…
seguimos.
(El artículo 220 da vía libre a las regiones
para crear empresas públicas y competir con
la iniciativa privada en cuánto sectores
consideren oportunos.
Evidentemente los políticos tienen muchos
incentivos para crear empresas públicas,
aunque solo sea para crear empleos a costa
del sector privado.
Asimismo también permirá que los políticos
puedan destituir por razones políticas a
los miembros que componen la junta del Banco
Central, limitando con ello claramente su
independencia.)
Por último, otra gran crítica es que la
Constitución incluye un enorme catálogo
de derechos sociales.
El problema es que además de limitar mucho
la elección política no deja claro cómo
pagarlos.
Por ejemplo, la nueva Constitución impone
la creación de un modelo de universidad pública
y gratuita.
Y ojo que esto es algo que como ya vimos en
VisualEconomik puede no ser la panacea que
muchos piensan.
De hecho los datos apuntñan que suele ser
una acción regresiva.
Paradogicamente, los mayores beneficiados
suelen ser las rentas más altas.
Para estos casos las becas generosas o la
financiación participativa suelen conllevar
mejores resultados…
Pero claro, desde el punto de vista de político
no es tan atractivo.
Así que la propuesta excluye esa posibilidad.
Otro ejemplo lo tenemos con el artículo 54
que obliga a crear un sistema público de
pensiones.
Lo cual puede estar muy bien si hablamos de
un modelo de protección asistencial.
El problema es que tal y como está redactado
el texto lo que hace es habilitar e, incluso,
incentivar que los gobiernos apuesten por
un sistema de reparto.
Un modelo que en la mayoría de países dónde
opera, como por ejemplo España, está fallando
estrepitosamente.
Basicamente porque no son sostenibles cuando
la población comienza a envejecer.
Pues bien estos 7 grupos, estos 7 grandes
temas: el derecho indígena, las cuotas, la
desaparición de contrapoderes, los cambios
del modelo económico, la sindicalización,
el intervencionismo y los derechos sociales
no financiados aglutinan algunas de las mayores
críticas que está recibiendo la propuesta.
Unas críticas que, por ejemplo, han hecho
que importantes figuras incluso del centro-izquierda
se hayan opuesto a ella.
Este es el caso, por ejemplo, del expresidente
Ricardo Lagos.
A principios de julio, un grupo de economistas
relevantes, en su mayoría de centroizquierda,
conocido como Convergencia Transversal, hizo
público un manifiesto en el que se afirmaba
que la la nueva constitución podría "afectar
gravemente a la estabilidad política y económica
del país", poniendo en peligro "su desarrollo
socioeconómico".
Y ojo, que incluso el propio gobierno de Gabriel
Boric ha tenido que salir al paso prometiendo
cambiar la Constitución si finalmente es
aprobada, para limar alguno de estos puntos.
Es decir, que ni el propio gobierno de izquierdas
la compra tal y como está:
N2(5 cambios que propone hacer el gobierno
de Chile al proyecto de Constitución si se
aprueba el texto.
BBC)
No sé, pero, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
No parece muy serio.
Os hemos hablado de ello en varias ocasiones
en Latampolitik - por cierto podéis recibir
este boletín si os unís a la comunidad de
VisualPolitik en Patreon:
El proceso constituyente ha sido una auténtica
chapuza.
La Convención no ha representado adecuadamente
los intereses del conjunto del país a la
hora de redactar su propuesta.
La Convención no ha trabajado para crear
un texto moderno que sea capaz de representar
a la inmensa mayor parte de los chilenos y
que al mismo tiempo sea capaz de promover
una mayor prosperidad económica.
Que más de la mitad de los chilenos se muestren
hoy desconfiados y contrarios hacía un texto
recien elaborado supuestamente para representar
a la mayoria dice mucho de lo que poco que
se ha logrado.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en Latinoamérica
existe una auténtica obsesión por cambiar
por completo las constituciones.
Es algo que en los últimos años se ha hecho
en Venezuela, en Bolivia y en Ecuador.
En todos los casos con pobres resultados.
Todo esto es quizás lo que explica que los
chilenos parezcan estar en contra de esta
Constitución.
Sea como sea si algo parece claro es que las
cosas no se han hecho nada bien.
Una Constitución tiene que buscar representar
a una amplia mayoría y no solo determinados
dogmas políticos.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Qué te parece esta nueva Constitución?
¿Merece la pena a cambiar tanto un modelo
que relativamente ha funcionado por otro que
incorpora muchas viejas recetas que siempre
fracasan?
Si nos estás viendo desde Chile, ¿votarás
a favor o en contra de esta Constitución?
Déjanos tus respuestas por aquí abajo en
los comentarios.
Y abramos debate.
Si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.